foreign
in I'm calling in to find out what your
guys thoughts advice is if we get
you know dumped in an instant into this
digital currency from our government
I mean what's what what are we supposed
to do are we supposed to be bringing
cash home are we what preparation
or do you think it's just something that
would take this is you know this is
something that would take a long time to
roll out and we'll have plenty of
warning can I be can I be super just
honest and direct is that cool
perfect okay so back in 2000 I think it
was 10 or maybe it was 2011. I was
um
crippled with anxiety
um okay my wife described me as being
married to a taser and my friends at
work
um they loved having me around because I
was good at my job and they couldn't
stand having me around because I was
always saying yeah but what about this
what about this what about this what
about this
and I had a buddy who's uh he's still
one of my closest Best Friends on the
planet and he works for the banking
commission and one day I had kind of
cornered him and this is as we're coming
out of the ashes of the market collapse
and housing implosion and
Roseanne I was I had came guns a blazing
and I know a lot about currency and I
know all about debt modeling and I was
going after him what about this what
about this and then what if this happens
what if this happens what if this
happens
and he finally said something to me
Roseanne that changed my entire life
he said this at one point he looked up
and realized I wasn't asking specific
questions I was trying to make him make
me feel better
and he looked at me and he said John I
don't have a meteorite plan
and I said what does that mean
and he said
dude if the currency crashes and
everything as we know it goes away
if we get hit by a meteorite
I'm not going to have spent time
planning for that because when that
happens everything in the world is
different from that moment forward in
his exact words he's my buddy so he said
by the time you're figuring out what to
do your neighbor would already be trying
to to
um take your pets for food like like we
think like if something happens we're
gonna prep in this way and this way
these big caustic things that we worry
about sometimes
I mean that's that's zombie stuff and so
if we woke up one day and our government
had taken all of our money out of our
accounts and turned it into digital
currency
that world would be so insanely
different from the world we inhabit
right now
that spending a second worrying about it
or trying to prep for it really isn't a
great use of your time
um
can I add to that of course go ahead
um you said something earlier when you
first
came on the call you said in an instant
if in an instant you know we moved to a
digital currency and my first thought I
kind of chuckled because I was like hey
these governments don't do anything in
an instant do you see how go go down to
the DMV they don't do anything in an
instant so that side of things I I
wouldn't be worried about but can I have
permission to can I be Reverend Jade for
a second
because yes there is part of this that
John touched on it you can't add a
single day or a year to your life by
being anxious that's what the Bible says
it says you know tomorrow has troubles
of its own just worry about today right
so just take it day day by day at a time
and things like this I'm going to just
tell you what Jade warshaw does one of
my favorite things that Dave says when
Dave's on air he says ultimately there's
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
and in these in the in the times that we
live in I don't care what time of period
you lived in nothing is going to give
you more peace we can tell you all the
data all the facts we can tell you read
all the articles but at the end of the
day the only person
or entity that's able to give you peace
in this world is Christ Jesus period I
don't care who's listening out there you
can believe what I believe or not but
that's the pathway to peace and I think
sometimes when we just start asking and
overflowing with all these questions
sometimes I just go back and I'm like
man this Earth has existed for thousands
and thousands and thousands of years
with so many crazy conditions if it
wasn't if it wasn't digital currency
it'd be a meteor you know hitting the
Earth and and you know destroying the
world to be the a dinosaur chasing after
you right so you just have to live in
the time that you live in and trust God
he numbers your days not digital
currency
for clarity Roseanne I I tend to think
that we're already there
um during covid the government
agents they deposited money in my
account they just put it in there they
just made it it's zeros and ones I mean
nothing happened they didn't send me a
paper check they just deposited it my
tax return this year uh was just
deposited in my account so my my
paycheck from Dave Ramsey he doesn't
sign a paycheck I just get it to pot so
we are already moving money originally
we're there if you're talking about
cryptocurrency and using blockchain
technology and all that I'm I'm of the
opinion that that is inevitable at some
point and it's not it doesn't have to be
a bad thing no I'm not worried about it
in the least when we get there we'll get
there but like Jade said I don't think
anything happens over and overnight but
I think so so many times John people get
like weird like apocalyptic and weirded
out by this and it's just like just get
in your car and go to work